[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique très
heureux de vous retrouver en direct ce
dimanche matin l'épidémie de corona
virus continue de se propager dans le
monde la france est toujours au stade 2
mais pourrait passer au stade 3 dans les
prochaines heures le stade iii étant
celui où l'on constate que le virus
circule et qu'il est transmissible sur
l'ensemble du territoire
alors où en est-on dans notre région les
pouvoirs publics ont-ils pris les
mesures efficaces
comment limiter la transmission du
coronavirus qu'est ce que le stade iii
et at on raison d'avoir peur ou au
contraire en fait en trop on en débat ce
matin avec nos invités docteur olivier
auvray je te bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le directeur général adjoint de l'agencé
régionale de santé bourgogne franche
comté la rs qui pilote cette lutte des
pouvoirs publics contre le corona virus
en région professeur lionel pirotte
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le chef du
service des maladies infectieuses et
tropicales du chu de dijon l'un des
hôpitaux qui accueillent donc les
malades du coronavirus dans notre région
docteur éric blondel bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le président des médecins
libéraux sein de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé vous qui nous
regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter cette émission en direct sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag dit
mme paul bourgogne alors avant d'en
venir à notre région docteur obrecht
j'ai envie de vous interroger sur ce qui
est en train de se passer en italie avec
des décisions draconiennes des régions
entières confiné ce sont plusieurs
millions d'habitants qui sont confinés
et puis des bars des restaurants des
théâtres complètement fermée sur
l'ensemble du territoire italien
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait nous arriver demain écoutez je
pense que en bourgogne franche comté on
en n'est clairement pas la maintenance
et ce sont des mesures qui sont adaptées
au stade 3 de l'épidémie au moment où il
convient d'essayer au maximum de limiter
le nombre de cas quand l'appartement wii
devient explosif
encore une fois ce n'est pas la
situation de la france vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un millier de cas
en france et nous avons des mesures de
confinement qui reste efficace la france
est au stade 2 nous ne sommes pas au
stade 2
de nouveaux voisins italiens professeur
karotz est efficace contre ce fameux
coronavirus qu'ovide 19 que de tenter de
confiner des régions entières à tout
dépend de ce qu'on cherche à faire c'est
sûr que afin de limiter l'épidémie puis
vous confie n'est plus une chance de
limiter l'expansion de de 2,9 à
l'apparition de nouveaux cas après tout
dépend du stade où on en est et c'est
vrai que plus on avance dans épidémie -
l'efficacité attendue est important
alors hier olivier aux brèches que vous
avez publié un nouveau communiqué comme
chaque jour est-ce que vous pouvez nous
faire un état des lieux de la situation
en bourgogne franche comté
oui alors effectivement comme vous le
signalez la situation est très évolutive
donc ce que je dis aujourd'hui sera
sûrement pas ce que je pourrais dire
demain est ce que ça veut dire que à 14h
vous allez faire un nouveau point dans
quelques dents quelques minutes tout à
fait et que vous allez annoncer de
nouveaux cas il y aura probablement
quelques nouveaux cas mais encore une
fois nous sommes dans une région où les
mesures qui ont été prises dans la phase
1 est dans la phase 2 désormais limite
de façon importante le nombre de cas
nous en avons 106 106 cas effectivement
hier à 16 heures
bon effectivement aujourd'hui il y en
aura probablement quelques uns de plus
nous avons six départements sur huit
dans la région qui sont touchés la
nièvre et l'yonne pour l'instant échappe
à l'épidémie
mais tous les autres départements où des
cas et on a deux départements le doubs
et le territoire de belfort qui sont
plus spécifiquement touchés que les
autres
est ce que la progression de secours au
navire us professeur pilotes et
spectaculaires ou est ce qu'elle est
normal pour ce type de virus qu'est ce
que vous direz c'est difficile de
répondre à ça d'une façon très très
simple et très tranché ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que je voudrais juste
rajouter une précision c'est que ça fait
deux mois qu'on est sur le coup ça fait
des années qu'on travaille ce genre
d'hypothèse qui ont déjà été
expérimenté dans le passé puisque on
accepte la première épidémie laquelle
elle est confrontée on a eu des virus
respiratoires qu'il a fallu gérer dans
le passé au cours d eau sera le strass
le maire ce des choses qui sont moins
connus du grand public
les à chanac saint cannat h7n7 donc
c'est des choses que les gens ne
connaissent pas oublier oublié ouais
c'est ça donc
et là en l'occurrence on a l'impression
que depuis huit jours dix jours on est
confronté à un énorme problème ça fait
deux mois qu'on travaille dessus de moi
qu'on sait qu'on a ce souci là
potentiellement puis qu'on a vu
apparaître progressivement donc ça on le
sait après dire que c'est ce qui se
passe est attendu c'est toujours
compliqué on souhaiterait toujours que
ce soit contingenté illimitée dès le
départ on voit bien qu'elle en
l'occurrence toutes les mesures qu'on a
mis en place n'ont pas suffi à limiter
la progression
il en demeure pas moins que ça se
rapproche d'autres d'autres épidémies
d'infection virale auxquels on est
confrontés régulièrement ce qui fait sa
spécificité que c'est que c'est un virus
nouveau qui qui qui se répand dans une
population qui n'a pas d'immunité
vis-à-vis de ce virus etc il n'existe
pas de vaccin
y a pas d'immunité déjà naturelle
naturelle pour monter des navires us il
ya déjà décoré d'un virus qui circulent
sur tout le monde a fait encore une à
virus oui c'est des rhumes sait des
choses comme ça et puis de temps en
temps le sait très bien
vous avez ces virus la kippa chez
l'animal donc on l'a vu avec des virus
de la grippe autrefois ils sont passés
chez le cochon chez les les
les oies sauvages par exemple ou dans le
cas du maire s'est passé chez le chameau
dont vous avez des recombinaisons qui se
font au sein entre les animaux et
l'homme et vous avez un virus qui du
coup acquiert des propriétés
particulières auxquelles la population
n'est pas préparé puisqu'on n'a pas
d'immunité qu'ont ces mutants là et là
c'est le cas en particulier la grande
question à chaque fois quand on voit
apparaître un mutant c est ce qu il est
plus contagieux et est-ce qu'il est plus
grave là en l'occurrence qu'est ce
qu'elle est plus contagieux on peut dire
que oui
la démonstration en est faite est ce
qu'il est plus grave c'est compliqué à
dire parce qu'on voit que tous les
modèles qu'on a extrapolé à partir de ce
qu'on sait en chine ce corrobore chez
nous on aurait même tendance à dire
qu'il est peut-être un peu moins grave
chez nous fait très très prudent quant à
ce que je dis mais n'assure donc on est
confronté à quelque chose qui est très
contagieux un peu grave je pas de
minimiser sa gravité ne fût ce que par
respect pour les gens qui sont en
réanimation vie malheureusement 17 du
fait de ce virus mais on peut dire que
voilà ccc on peut pas dire qu'on avait
prévu les choses pour ce virus
par contre ça rentre dans des modèles
que vous connaissez d'infection auquel
on a été confrontés et auquel on sera
confrontés c'est à dire que cette
histoire là
va survenir on fera les comptes à la fin
de cette épidémie mais on aura à gérer
des cas similaires dans le futur
d'octobre des vous vous êtes un les
médecins libéraux en première ligne sur
les virus en permanence et notamment en
période hivernale
comment vous abordez cette épidémie là
est ce qu elle pour vous allez très
différente des autres
les différents dans le sens où elle est
pourvoyeuse grande inquiétude on a eu
tous les débats qui a pu y avoir plus ou
moins justifiées mais vis-à-vis d'un
d'un agent biologique ne émergents comme
l'inde et le docteur pirotte on est sur
l'inconnu quelle quelle va être
l'évolution qu'avec la pénétration dans
la population qui va être le le taux de
morbidité associée
cet agent dans le monde on sait rien
c'est sa plus grande crainte à vous
c'est que finalement on le même si on
travaille sur des modèles depuis
longtemps qui peuvent ressembler on le
connaît pas secours au navire russe l'a
alors il ya toujours cette part
d'inquiétudes lié à l'ignorance ou en
tout cas la meilleure connaissance
possible aux connaissances actuelles
d'où une situation très évolutive la
deuxième chose c'est la crainte d'être
quand on est malade on va voir un
médecin donc le médecin peut être un
point de transmission et donc ça c'est
une inquiétude ou en tout cas une
préoccupation constante des
professionnels de santé et pas que des
libéraux qui est de dire je ne dois pas
être un réseau un vecteur de
transmission d'un agent émergents on a
fait le compte des chiffres docteur
obrecht est-ce que c'est toujours une
histoire de chiffres est ce qu on en est
toujours à une histoire de chiffres et à
quel moment on comptera plus parce que
finalement on compte pas les cas de
grippe
je pense qu'il faut bien voir que la
situation est différente selon les zones
du territoire c'est à dire que les
endroits on a encore que quelques cas
qui sont tracés que peut repérer et
suivre ça reste extrêmement important de
d'une part de évidemment de soigner les
patients de repérer les cas contacts
dans leur environnement pour permettre
d'avoir cette je dirais ce confinement
maximum des cas après lorsqu'on est dans
des zones où le virus circule déjà plus
je dirais plus largement comme on l'a
par exemple je vous dis dans certains
départements doubs le territoire de
belfort
là le sujet c'est effectivement de faire
l'information les trois trépied de
l'action publique lassée véritablement
repérer les patients pour les soigner
informer leur entourage pour qu'il soit
le moins transmetteur possible et là on
rejoint ce que disait le docteur blondet
par rapport à la chaîne de transmission
et le troisième élément important sur
lesquels nous travaillons désormais à la
grèce c'est protéger les soignants
puisque c'est effectivement quand nous
allons entrer en phase 3 parce que je ne
sais pas si c'est dizier quelques heures
quelques jours c'est peut-être quelques
soirées conseil de défense ce soir allez
louis et bien sûr et mais ça sera de
toute façon vraisemblablement des
attitudes qui seront construites et
c'est à dire on voit bien déjà que la
situation de l'oise n'est pas du tout la
situation de la côte d'or et a fortiori
de l'yonne ou de la nièvre
donc il faut garder au territoire une
fois garder des stratégies différenciées
sur les territoires et la protection des
professionnels de santé évidemment des
soins de premier recours les médecins
traitants les infirmières libérales mais
aussi les personnes notamment dans les
ehpad qui prennent en charge les
patients pour qu'on ait effectivement ce
même trajet de contamination et de
chaînes de transmission direction des
plus fragiles je posais la question du
chiffre professeur pilotes parce que
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus dépisté tout
le monde à partir du moment où le où le
virus circule autant il ça n'aurait
presque pas de sens non non ça rejoint
tout à fait la réponse qui vient de vous
être être tout dépend du stade vous en
êtes si vous êtes effectivement dans une
situation territoriales qui fait que
vous avez un très très grand nombre de
cas dépistés tout le monde n'a plus
vraiment de sens c'est à dire qu'on va
préjugés que les gens sont atteints par
excès plutôt que de ne pas le faire par
défaut à la verse quand vous avez des
mondes des quatre qui sont encore
limités en nombre dans un territoire
c'est important de continuer à dépister
pour essayer de limiter encore la
propagation sur le territoire comme ça
tu peux pas garder en l'état actuel des
choses réponse univoque et unique pour
tout le monde tout dépend de la
situation géographique dans laquelle
vous vous trouvez
gray mesure dépendront de cette
situation oui et je dirais de ce point
de vue je voudrais renforcer ce qui
vient d'être dit il ya véritablement une
prise de conscience collectif qu'il faut
avoir par rapport à cela c'est à dire
que les mesures dites barrière que l'on
applique
généralement en cas d'épisode de
grippale en cas d'épisodes infectieux
elles ont tout leur sens là puisqu'un
virus égale un virus par rapport à cette
modalité transmission c'est à dire
réduire réduire ses contacts sociaux se
laver les mains ne pas aller embrasser
sa grand-mère quand on a de la fièvre
ils ont tous ce sont des mesures de
prévention ubiquitaire qui à ce stade
sont véritablement parmi les plus
efficaces et qu'il faut véritablement
martèlement devraient pratiquer pour
l'hiver notamment pour éviter le sol de
la grippe c'est absolument
c'est pour ça par rapport à votre
question est ce qu'on en fait trop la
bonne question pourrait être aussi qu
est-ce qu on n'en fait pas assez
non pas cette fois ci mais le choix
d'avoir des fois d'avoir une fois à
venir hier j'ai bien fait tout ce qu'on
est en train de marteler à l'occasion du
gros navires us ce sont des mesures
qu'on devrait déjà plié qui devrait être
dans nos gènes dans notre culture pour
le coup ça va changer un peu les choses
mais j'espère 6,6 pente est si ça change
pas les choses à cette occasion là ça
sera à désespérer un moment ou un autre
mais je pense que la question c'est
plutôt est ce qu'on n'en a pas fait
assez avant plutôt qu'en faire trop
maintenant alors vous êtes tenus au
secret médical évidemment professeur
pirates mais comment ça se passe de
manière générale dans votre service le
service des maladies infectieuses et
tropicales du chu de dijon où des
malades sont hospitalisés pour secours
au navire
alors il faut savoir donc comme je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est quelque
chose à quoi on se prépare depuis deux
mois avec notre direction avec nos
services partenaires il faut savoir que
tous les services sont mobilisés que ce
n'est pas qu'un service qui travaille
sur le sur ce thème là et qui a envisagé
qu'à prévu et qui s'occupe de la prise
en charge maintenant des patients
infectés par le le corrélat virus donc
cette approche multidisciplinaire elle
s'est mise en place progressivement elle
s'affine elle s'ajuste l'on n'est pas
opérationnel maintenant depuis à peu
près deux mois ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est qu'on est encore dans
une zone de densité virale on va dire
relativement faible en côte d'or c'est à
dire que on a pas qu'à on en a
maintenant depuis une dizaine de jours
que jusqu'à présent on arrive toujours à
les pister a sérié et à orienter les
gens de la façon la plus adéquate
possible c'est à dire que quand en
l'état actuel des choses ils vont très
bien
on a mis en place un processus de
surveillance à domicile sont des gens
qu'on appelle régulièrement quitte à les
faire revenir le lac si jamais ça
n'allait pas bien et puis ceux qui ne
vont pas bien et où pour lesquelles on a
un doute parce qu'ils sont fragiles et
ou parce qu'ils ne comprennent pas
forcément tous les enjeux de la
situation
est ce qu'on les fait venir dans le
service et on les rend les on les garde
en hospitalisation le temps qu'il faut
ça vous n'êtes pas submerger ni vous dit
même les autres aux autres tournées ans
a émergé pour la simple et bonne raison
qu'on s'adapte c'est à dire faut pas
voir les choses d'une façon dogmatique
on est très pragmatique
c'est à dire qu'on a redimensionné grâce
à comment dirais-je à l'implication de
tous et notamment donc du chu dans son
intégralité on à redimensionner nos
moyens et on s'adapte c'est à dire que
au départ on avait dit réservé un
certain nombre de chambres et puis le
nombre de chambres a évolué et on adapte
de dispositifs en permanence ça ne veut
pas dire que l'on n'a pas anticipé non
les filières et les procès s'ils sont
très claires c'est le dimensionnement
c'est à dire s'adapter on s'est adapté à
l'actualisation d'un mois olivier
humbrecht aujourd'hui on hospitalise
plus forcément avant ou au début de
l'épidémie on hospitalise est pour
contenir l'évolution du virus
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est plus
forcément nécessaire oui tout à fait
d'ailleurs dans les 106 cas qu'on
évoquait plus de 50% aujourd'hui déjà de
ces cas sont à domicile sont suivies à
domicile comme vient de l'évoquer love /
pirotte donc il ça c'est évidemment la
tendance importante
à partir du moment où on a évidemment
les gens restent à domicile bien sûr
l'idée c'est pas d'eux qu'ils soient
dans la ville et qu'ils sont suivis en
tant que de besoin par ailleurs on en a
pas encore on en a deux dans la région
aujourd'hui mais on a aussi faut pas
l'oublier c'est un épisode virale qui
dans la majorité des cas restent quand
même un épisode bénin et les gens
guérissent
c'est à dire que sur les 106 cas qu'on a
aujourd'hui repérer on a déjà deux
personnes de vous qualifier comme guéri
abeilles sont guéris ou sont en effet
sortir de série donc donc ils vont bien
et je reviens sur un point que vous avez
mentionné quand vous avez dit qu'on
hospitalisé parce que c'était le fait
d'être en ville ne veut pas dire qu'on
lâche la faire s'il autorise non non non
mais personne ne bougeait pas si j'ose
dire exactement fait c'est la
responsabilité tout un chacun et la
responsabilisation des gens en leur
expliquer la plupart des gens sont bien
réceptifs à ce message là c'est à dire
que le fait d'être en ambulatoire d'être
à la maison ne veut pas dire que on
favorise la propagation de l'infection
l'amour sur les patients qui sont dans
votre service ils vont bien comment vous
dire voyez bien fou ils vont bien enfin
il faut voir quelque chose c'est que
l'épidémie les chiffres qu'on a deux
chine ce sont à peu près ce qu'on peut
observer actuellement en france à savoir
quand vous faites une infection par le
corona virus dans 85% des cas vous allez
faire une infection vous allez allait
parfaitement bien et vous allez avoir
une infection qui
nous ne suscitera pas d'inquiétude
particulière qu'ils allaient avoir 15 %
de gens qui vont avoir besoin de
totaliser pour une raison et
malheureusement vous allez avoir 5 % de
gens qui vont relever de soins intensifs
et deux portions de gens ou actuellement
qui laissait donc faut pas passer d'un
extrême à l'autre d'un côté dire sa
carrière et de l'autre côté c'est grave
non on se retrouve avec un panel de
situations qui vont varier notamment
fonction de la population concernée
parce que il là encore il ya des
messages très clairs à faire passer il
les enfants de moins de 15 ans les
formes graves c'est exceptionnel et
al'inverse malheureusement les patientes
qui a 70 ans ou 80 ans et ce sont les
personnes les plus à risque donc la
réponse sera là encore un peu a varié
selon la population laquelle on
s'adresse d'octobre ont des on dit que
donc les hôpitaux gère et s'adapte vos
cabinets médicaux en ville à l'est la
médecine de ville comme on dit dans le
langage courant aujourd'hui ils sont
submergés par cette question parce que
là c'est pareil au début on nous a dit
faut pas bouger il faut appeler le
centre 15 mai à partir du moment où on a
quelque chose qui ressemble à des
syndromes grippaux
j'imagine qu'on va voir son médecin
traitant enfin je moi c'est ce que je
ferais je sais pas ce que font ceux qui
nous regardent mais qu'est-ce que vous
conseiller de faire ce qui est conseillé
c'est les recommandations actuelles en
tête 2 c on a le moindre doute on
appelle le centre 15 plutôt que d'aller
dans une salle d'attenté éventuellement
avec plusieurs personnes qui a tenté de
contaminer de lecteurs de comptes ajoute
ça ça reste vrai ça ça reste vrai qu'on
est en tête 2 cependant le doute c'est
quoi le syndrome grippal c'est un salon
de viral donc dès qu'on a un syndrome
grippal
comme c'était mon cas il ya quinze jours
j'appelle le centre 15 plutôt que de
prendre rendez vous chez mon médecin
traitant en tant qu on est en ligue 2
oui cela m'évite confia les contacts de
d'autres gens et notamment dans les
milieux confinés et le premier milieu
confiné de jean balade c'est quand même
une salle d'attenté de médecin ou deux
professionnels de santé donc ça c'est du
bon sens et du pragmatisme comme le
disait plus haut à partir du moment où
on passerait au stade 3 et on va venir
au rôle du stade iii mais ça changerait
sans doute les choses vous seriez du
coup encore plus en première ligne on
verra toujours en première ligne
jamais mort d'andré quand on est malade
notre second s'en va rarement
directement voir le professeur pirotte
voit normalement tout à fait
ensuite il va y avoir
besoin d'un suivi l'évolution voulait
bien noté les situations sont très
hétérogènes
c'est une véritable mosaïque sur le
territoire et des clusters très fort et
d'autres qui sont où il ya peu ou pas de
cas on a deux départements où il y en a
pas et donc automatiquement
il va pas y avoir de solution immédiate
et universel a apporté ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il est de la responsabilité de tous
possèdent le sentent et de se préparer à
cette évolution alors ça c'est le rôle
des huées repaissent de transmettre
régulièrement des informations à jour
donc on est en lien avec la rs unions
régionales des professionnels de santé
ars agence régionale de sa 200e et on
est en lien également avec les autorités
nationales on incite nos nos mandants et
donc tous les médecins libéraux à
s'abonner à la baisse à la messagerie
la direction générale de la santé suivre
cette évolution à regarder les points de
situation est donc à commencer à
réfléchir
de quelle serait leur organisation si on
devait passer en face notamment éviter
le contact entre les patients alors
c'est le monde en salle date un c'est
pas d'éviter c'est de réorganiser son
cabinet pour éviter la concentration de
patients potentiellement porter ça c'est
le premier point de privilégier des soit
peut-être plus à domicile ou des
télésoins et là c'est tout l'enjeu du
développement et de l'accélération du
déploiement de la télémédecine vous
demander des moyens supplémentaires on
entend certains syndicats de médecins
libéraux dire on air on n'est pas assez
armé contre ce virus
qu'est ce qu'on entend par mais s'il
s'agit de la protection individuelle
il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes chez
possible de santé de ce fait si on prend
un chirurgien dentiste quand on dit la
double barrière c'est difficile de
traiter en hongrie
un patient avec un masque quand le
patient doit porter le mal et
respiratoires il ya l'estomac tous les
horaires elle je sais pas il ya cette
affaire de masques est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes hasard et l'impression que
vous avez les bons masquer les bons
outils pour pour vous prémunir et
prémunir aussi vos patients parce que
c'est quand même ça l'idée alors oui il
ya des dotations qui ont été libérés par
le par l'état par le gouvernement sont
des masques chirurgicaux masques
chirurgicaux donc rien à voir avec les
ffp2 non mais encore autre chose
encore une fois je suis pas
épidémiologistes je suis pas
infectiologues donc tourner vers le
professeur piratés pour le moment les
informations qui me sont transmises
c'est que dans un crucifix bénin et
quand on n'est pas porteur soi-même de
comorbidité qui est aux un risque de
formes graves
la double barrière du masque apportée
par le patient et par le praticien
mais il en faut
j'ai bien compris parce accroc les
changer régulièrement je sais pas voilà
il ya un effet volume ensuite
effectivement il ya eu des remontées en
disant oui mais mon masque arrivants
péremption en 2000 mars 2001 oui 31 mars
2020 puisqu'il faut bien voir c'est
qu'il ya un mouvement de panique aussi
qui a eu lieu d'équivalent de panique
dans la population tout le monde a
cherché à se procurer du masque de la
solution hydro alcoolique et tout ça a
mis en tension à la fois les capacités
de production et de distribution
et là il ya aussi qu'il a une
responsabilité collective de garder son
sang froid
olivier humbrecht le stade iii il est
inéluctable selon gouvernement les
différentes prises de position des
ministres tendent à le dire est ce qu'il
faut passer au stade 3 et j'ai envie de
dire pourquoi attendre alors je pense
qu'il est on ne peut pas faire de
d'anticipation et ce qu'il faut ce qui
est inéluctable la cinétique des
épidémies habituel laisse penser qu'on
va passer au stade 3 si on regarde ce
qui se passe autour de nous pour autant
je pense que l'important c'est ce que la
fois le dr blondel professeur pirates
ont dit c'est à dire c'est l'adaptation
en continu en temps réel du système avec
notamment les réorientations d'activité
qui peuvent être nécessaires en fonction
du nombre de cas qu'on aura c'est vrai
que si aujourd'hui nous avons deux
patients en réanimation sur no 106 dans
la région si demain on n'avait pas cent
six patients mais vingt mille patients
il est évident que nous aurions avec les
établissements à anticiper la façon dont
les établissements publics de premier
recours
les établissements publics de second
recours parce qu'on oublie aussi tous
les établissements et les établissements
privés un certain nombre
d'établissements privés court derrière
essayer c'est le nombre simplement le
nombre de personnes s'y fier alors c'est
pas que le nombre je compléterai
peut-être monsieur période mais ce n'est
pas que le nombre c'est aussi la vitesse
de diffusion dans un dans un groupe de
population et c'est pour ça par exemple
que le haut-rhin et l'oise ont été de
fait passé en stade de renforcer mais
les mesures qui sont prises avec ta
soirée mesure de 7,3 à ce qu'à ce moment
là le sujet c'est bien de briser le
l'évolution de la courbe d'évolution du
nombre de cas nous on a encore une fois
je le redis on n'en est pas là et notre
enjeu désormais c'est bien de préparer
d'anticiper on en aura peut-être pas
besoin mais probablement que ça sera
utile ça fait parti libéral
notamment la façon ce que vient de dire
le dr blondel les patients lorsqu'on va
plus tous les tester lorsque le centre
15 sera rassuré quelqu'un qui sans doute
est touché mais va bien va rester à
domicile
comment les médecins traitants vont
pouvoir prendre le relais y compris de
façon dématérialisée et nous allons
essayer de travailler effectivement
d'ores et déjà sur la façon dont les
patients à domicile pourront contacter
laure leur médecin habituel par voie par
votre télé sans moi j'ai fait un
commentaire qui n'engage que moi mais je
pense qu'il ya une réflexion à porter
parce que c'est clair que ce stade iii
et comment dirais-je agitée comme étant
la troisième guerre mondiale la lumière
mozilla ou que sais-je encore la vraie
différence entre le stade et le stade 2
j'allais dire le 2 le 3 c'est juste un
dimensionnement la philosophie est la
même
vous appelez ça de plus 3 - 2 5 de 800cc
pas le problème alors pourquoi je dis
faudra réfléchir c'est qu'il fut il y
avait des plans autres fois où on avait
plus de stade
donc c'était peut-être moins
traumatisante passé trois plats de 8 4 à
5 900 cas si c'était là dans un but de
simplification série 2 à 3 mais on se
rend compte par le discours quel est le
vôtre et techniques et souvent le celui
qu'on entend dans la population générale
que le 3 ça essayez ça serait la
catastrophe non de 3 c'est pareil c'est
juste une question de dimensionnement
pour vous ça va changer votre façon de
travailler
pas tellement le relais nathalie 0 et
jeanne mance et laissé plus
l'implication de la fin des chats les
médecins libéraux sont impliqués parce
qu'on a besoin d'eux il faut déjà le
savoir c'est qu'on travaille déjà avec
des médecins la médecine ambulatoire et
la médecine de ville et simplement c'est
le dimensionnement qui va changer donc
que ça soit 3 c'est spectaculaire savait
faire frémir dans les chaumières
peut-être ça ne devrait pas ça ne
devrait pas dr blondel le le stade 3 ça
va être très important pour vous le
statut fondamental parce que finalement
les prises en charges qui ont été mises
en place avec les mesures précaution par
hbo personnel à l'hôpital bon devront
être transcrites en médecine de ville
donc là effectivement ça ou des
questions mais sur lesquelles on échange
régulièrement avec les services de la rs
sur les moyens de protection
individuelle alors j'ai vu qu'on a
évoqué les masques esa chafaï solution
hydro alcoolique se pose aussi la
question des lunettes de protection des
sur blues qui sont jetables et qu'ils
doivent être incinérés après donc la
ensuite c'est toute une logistique
derrière
selon lesquelles on travaille que les
cabinets de ville n'ont pas forcément
l'habitude de lire et que j'ai alors à
l'hôpital s'achèvera l'avant sur la
destruction d
des déchets compagnie les dasri et avec
aussi un impact économique soit cabine
équivalent avec le sauf que j'imagine
que le virus sur un sur une blouse il
tient pas longtemps on a pas longtemps
mais à la lumière de ce qu'on vous dit
il faut bien voir ses organisationnel
c'est à dire que le 2 le 3 au niveau de
la population c'est juste une question
d'organisation accord juste ça veut pas
minimiser le fait je dirais juste quand
même beaucoup de choses à mettre en
place mais certaines sont déjà en train
de se mettre en place donc moins bien
pendant 7 à 2 je pense qu'on sera tous
d'accord pour né à 2,2 sais pas quoi de
renforcer des départements et donc et
encore une fois cela dépend du séjour ou
du trois mois afin qu'on voulait c'est
ça veut pas dire que l'organisation à
mettre en place ça naît ça serait bien
que la presse doit ses seins parce que
la difficulté c'est pas finalement qu'
il faut un compromis entre les
précautions à prendre et le fait qu'on
doit aussi continuer à vivre on voit ce
qui se passe en italie on se dit que
jusqu à quel moment on continue à vivre
normalement avec un virus comme celui-là
qui circulent oui c'est ça finalement
encore une fois je pense qu'il n'y a pas
deux il ya pas de solution toute faite
c'est les réalités locales
et si on devait avoir des zones dans la
région qui passe en stade 3 comme dit
professeur pirotte c'est +11 enjeux
organisationnels et là on est en contact
évidemment étroit avec les autorités de
l'état et notamment les préfets par
rapport à la limitation des activités
qui pourraient avoir lieu d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour le dit la rentrée des
classes c'est demain oui dans la région
bourgogne pas de mesures particulières
pour les écoles collèges et lycées pour
la mesure particulière en bourgogne
franche comté la rentrée aura donc lieu
normalement il y a aucun établissement
scolaires fermé et aucun élève n'est a
priori ne doit a priori rester chez lui
quel que soit l'endroit d'où il vient y
compris s'il est allé passer ses
vacances en bretagne alors professeur
pire peut-être d'un mot est ce qu'on est
ce qu'on doit s'attendre à une surprise
est ce que on parle d'eux
d'un virus qui pourrait muter d'une
accélération des contaminations est ce
que c'est des choses auxquelles on doit
s'attendre
ou est ce qu'on ne doit pas s'inquiéter
est ce que vous le savez d'ores et déjà
vous qui êtes au contact de ce virus
quotidiennement d'un mot vous êtes dur
parce que plusieurs notions de oui je
vais essayer d'être ratée à un virus qui
mute un virus qui mute non il faudra y
retourner à l'animal mais par contre on
en aura d'autres dans le futur par une
accélération des contaminations rapport
à celui là on le voit on le voit déjà un
virus qu'elle comptait de la gravité
celle qu'on attendait au vu des données
chinoises
donc ça cher voilà ils ont géré cette
épidémie la durée d'une telle épidémie
est ce que est ce qu'avec la fin de
l'hiver comme la grippe et de la loge
oui je ne suis pas une idéologie ce mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut espérer sur des
dossiers d'hémisphère sud même s'il ya
des différences au niveau du système de
santé on peut espérer que avec les blés
le beau temps enfin leur rêve
le retour du printemps et l'été cette
épidémie stas mais ces conjectures
c'est une vieille brest un conseil à
donner à tous ceux qui nous regardent là
tout de suite propos qui s'inquiète
finalement de cette épidémie
je pense qu'il faut être vigilant et
appliquer les mesures encore une fois
barrière général qui souhaitait qu'ils
ont été rappelés donc alors attention
bien se laver les mains régulièrement
utiliser des mouchoirs jetables ce qu'on
devrait faire pour une grippe classique
tout à fait sagna pas d'un mal plus
efficaces et par rapport aux solutions
hydroalcooliques et aux délires co2
alors vous prenez un savon et de l'eau
le problème c'est qu'il faut de l'eau
ces mois-là ont privilégié les solutions
hydroalcooliques n'ai pas besoin de
faire tout le temps oui exactement
mais le savons et l'eau sont tout aussi
efficaces donc fait les mesures
barrières
c'est la meilleure protection vous
puissiez de merci merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis aujourd'hui si
vous avez d'autres questions
je vous rappelle qu'un numéro de
téléphone a été mis en place le 0 800
130 000 il est gratuit accessible 24
heures sur 24
jours sur sept dans un instant un point
sur l'actualite